[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about
contemporary sacred art we have
Ksenia ha joining us on the show hi
thanks so much for coming on so excited
to host you thank you imitation you're
super welcome and it was very fun
attending your be art community events
and learning more about your
contemporary sacred art when I first saw
it I was like this takes a lot of skill
and practice and it speaks really
interesting messages that we'll get to
talk about today those that don't know
Ksenia background she is a contemporary
sacred artist whose work uses
photography 3d and old gilding
techniques to create parallel realities
you can find the link in the bio below
to her website as well as her Instagram
page alright Senya let's start things
off by asking you what are your thoughts
on the direction of our world like where
we are going yes like where we're
heading so I will I'll tell you like the
true would like the truth that I'm
thinking yes I think that we're like
this spiral moving all the time and we
actually moving right now from the very
on from the edge to the center kind of
like we as a if we imagine all the
people as a1 like one person like one
body we all are moving to be back into
our selves so we're moving to the world
being more more beautiful and better and
more thing and more sensitive yeah oh
yeah that's totally what it feels like
as well we're in a sense we had a period
of what seems like a disconnection from
nature disconnection from source
disconnection from who we are like our
own authenticity for every single one of
the humans it seems like sometimes when
we walk around on the streets that
people are doing things that is clearly
not their calling clearly not their
northstar theirs they're clearly not
doing what they're passionate about and
so we're fixing that in a sense I feel
like the world is changing and if you
remember us as people like 100 hundred
years ago who we were I think we're
coming to much much much to our truth
yes it takes longer and we can see it
during our life just because they take
so long but actually I feel I truly feel
that our direction moving in a really
beautiful place yeah yeah and also like
that process is a process of growth and
transformation it takes a while
sometimes for these cycles of the
caterpillar turning into the butterfly
and sometimes it takes some pain it
takes some healing that we have to do in
order to get there but it's also
beautiful as we go burst out of the
cocoon
you know fly all of us with our own
passions and our own talents sending
let's talk about the journey of how you
got interested in contemporary sacred
art how did you pick this up when you
were growing up and tell us about your
life journey
honestly it is so hard question I don't
know because I think so I was a teenager
and I was I've like I think everybody
would say it but yes I felt very
different you know from everybody so I
was I have I had a lot of inner worlds
inside me and I don't know I was reading
some strange books and some philosophy
since I was a child and I always felt
that like I'm strange and you know I
need to do with this something it's a
good feeling to feel like I'm strange
yeah I'm unique I need to express myself
I felt like I'm strange at school so
when I am different and I will I lived
in Kherson it's like small city in
activity Union country Ukraine like is
so gray and it's so I don't know
everything not moving anywhere nothing
building just everything just destroyed
and you see this of it Union everywhere
so it's pretty depressing how many
people live in that city I mean it's not
too small I think it's three times less
than San Francisco but summer discuss
pretty small right different maybe like
300 thousand people or so I'm not I'm an
artist you know whoa okay so tell us
more about you growing up there yeah
yeah and then I attended to this art
exhibition with like the children drew
something and I'm like oh my god this is
so there's something that spoke to me I
I said to my mother that I want to do
the same I want to try the same so we
went to this art school and again for
small City as any like in Ukraine this
was kind of like a hog words for me yeah
it was just it blew my mind and I felt
that to be strange there it's cool like
it is in school it's you try to be as
everybody try to not mess up like try to
be like I am I'm okay but in art school
like all this uniqueness it actually
works and I'm like oh my god okay by the
way yeah more unique yeah yeah that's
cool so I felt that oh my god this is my
awkward this is actually there were no
hard water that those time movies so but
anyway it's it's actually I then moved
to Kiev to capital and then I moved here
but still I would say given once you
move to be um I moved to take you when I
was studying at the University so like
is anything to you yeah and here three
years ago so years ago see like 21 it's
you moved yeah yeah how did how did it
come up that you decided to make
to the United States it's a hard move
that's a you know cross you know
actually it's not my even not a dream
not wish is just circumstances just life
brought me here with my ex man that was
in IT company and they the yeah so they
had a team here in the United States and
they just invited him for one year but
but then we decided to like we didn't
understand something we need one year
more and then we drifted apart
why shouldn't we and yeah this is our
state okay and then you started making
our right when you got here it were in
college we were making them oh yeah
actually so I started so I started from
that little art school and then I
decided to stop going at school and
moved to college switch to college is to
art college just because it's like my
environment and my people and yeah I but
I would say that the division what I'm
doing right now I think I started
actually like three years ago or three
four years ago yeah whenever like a
little bit before that I would and here
actually so I did everything here all
all this weekend most of the stuff that
we saw in the video
yeah yeah yeah yeah because before like
before I was searching for this style
and for the main my main media and yeah
so my leg a unique style yeah yeah we
have to find out how you found out about
this style how you created this yeah I
can tell by the
forever great yeah so the I used the
photography as but I'm not a
photographer I actually don't know how
to make photos honestly it's not my my
power I'm Marley artist and photography
I'm using only as a as a just background
it's something that I can work with as a
cat my canvas so actually the the
movement in itself made this change to
the photography just because when I was
moving from Kiev I couldn't take all
these cameras that I had I was painting
in oil and I'm like okay I have like
this huge canvases but what can I do
with this like nothing so this I this
actually this made this huge change in
my vision of my art because I wanted to
take it anywhere because I wanted to be
as light as possible so I can just pack
my computer and I have all my art there
so this was one of the reason and
another still I was searching right and
and I came to the portraits and right
before I moved I was studying sacred
icons you know investing in Russian
Church you see this icons right like
there's lots of sacred symbols yeah yeah
yeah so I was learning this technique
like art docks
Orthodox techniques for two years and I
really like that time and because I was
searching the meaning behind the art
right so I had my questions and I went
to go to find those answers in Orthodox
techniques and Sakura art so I went
there and I was lucky enough to have
really great teachers that I was
questioning them like why would we draw
this type of face like how do you know
that all these people look like this or
why would we use these lines or what
like you know all these questions and
[Music]
whatever what I came actually in my own
process of understanding that I want to
be as like as pure as possible in this
cyclonus I don't want to imagine in
anybody like I don't know to imagine any
person that probably existed exist in
the past
so my answer that I found that this God
that I'm looking in my life in my art
it's like in every person yeah
this is why I'm making pictures real
people I'm not drawing anybody from the
past or from my imagination I I have
pictures of real people and then this is
these are photographs yes real high
quality photograph yeah real people yes
and then then you do your 3d layering
yes and then I use all some of the
techniques that I've learned from the
sacred art adducts art and yeah and add
some of the contemporary Ness with the
3d by using also this gilding technique
it's also old right it's like thousand
thousand years of it it's like started
from Egypt even and then come from
bromine from okay like it went through
all this our story history how did oh
and roasting our art our story our
Theory our street city history
yeah that's funny yeah our our story
like
oh yeah so I like that a lot so so then
what is like you know okay we're gonna
talk about you know what you're just
getting at how you go but like you
wanted to showcase the divinity within
all of us God within all of us yeah and
in real people yeah and not like seeing
things from 100,000 years ago being like
how do you know they look like that or
whatever but this is like I'm gonna take
real high high quality images of people
yes okay and then interesting so you
landed on this and then did you
immediately like how did you figure out
that you wanted to do the the 3d layer
techniques and they field techniques how
did you figure that out because um I
want to be I would I don't know if it
happens but what I'm dreaming about is
I'm dreaming to change the contemporary
art like I'm dreaming to change the
environment in the museum's and how the
works are showing also because I think
so
just imagine again all the history that
we had that old people in all times they
had so much connection with discretion
Who am I or why the world diseases or
like what is going on around me what is
this all about
so all these questions they were either
questioning in art either trying to find
the answer in art this is why like
remember Egypt right Oh what they were
drawing on the walls it was about God
remember Roma or Greece they were doing
goodness like yes sculptures of who God
or like whatever you like Japanese Thai
bit mm-hmm and it was going for
thousands thousands thousands years and
boom something switched and we from the
question Who am I what I'm doing there
here like who created me or what's going
on Who am I
we switch to I want like or I want show
myself you know so it like from these
came to to like a very narrow I no
question or answer even something
interesting okay so this is this
actually speaks a lot to your study of
philosophy when you're younger and
you're like you're like I'm so weird I
don't I hear you now that's great the
those questions it does seem like we got
disconnected from asking those questions
especially really recently you look back
just several hundreds even thousands of
years it just really people were more
obsessed with asking Who am I
what is this creation that we all live
on this planet how did it come why am I
here
and what are these gods that could have
potentially yeah and then so then so now
would you say that then the conversation
has moved more towards how do I make my
paint stroke on the canvas of creation
like yeah how how how how am i cool and
unique in this world or something like
how am i what you know yes like not what
am i and what I can give but what I can
take interesting so we need to then we
need to create more value than we
capture so we need to make more than we
take that's been like a principle that I
think is really important yeah so so
what I see right now in the contemporary
art and why I want to be in it just
because I see that contemporary art is
very very very disconnected right now
from the audience like from the usual
people like most of the people yeah it's
a good question like what's of the
people if I was a even 90% of the people
when they go to the modern or
contemporary art like museums they would
try to understand but it would be mostly
something from their mind but not from
the heart so it will be ok I get it he
meant this this and this maybe it's cool
but you want them to to feel more I want
to feel more and have much bigger
questions like from base to like like to
the universe questions questions yeah
this size of use how then how does your
art do that because you're trying to
shift the contemporary art sacred art
scene maybe you're trying to shift
contemporary art more towards sacredness
and the bigger questions and stuff and
then how does your art do that
yeah probably I would not I wouldn't say
that I want to shift it to the
sacredness because it's my questions
right this is what I'm interested and
it's totally find that if other people
not interested yes in such questions
yeah same thing what the show is like if
yeah if people don't like the questions
they watch other shows yeah yeah but
yeah because I see my art is it speaks
to the past and it speaks to now and it
speaks to the future like it speaks
through the past for the ideas and first
like gilding techniques for example and
this icons that I've the technique of
icons that I have learned and nowadays
just because I use the photography and
the printing and stuff in this 3d is
actually cut in the future because I
also right now learn learning VR and AR
- for example when you see the image and
then you can use your phone and then it
start to like something moves and show
you like story about what is this houses
like or somehow interacts with you
it'd be like when you go up to your art
yeah you seem that they get to actually
maybe wearing a are we get to see the
story of yeah why yeah came up yet or
maybe it will be like
kind of like again the parallel reality
that you wear these glasses and you see
that actually this works like maybe in a
in a gallery that looks like an example
you know like so past contemporary and
future okay all in one yes yeah and this
is I think that this language is I think
I hope that is pretty unique and it has
like very like it has a lot a lot a lot
a lot of layers I would say like four
different yes people and four different
depth yes and it's also and also in a
way is beautiful so my personal desire
is to see the beauty in the art
galleries and museums because sometimes
you can see and and again I understand
all the all the story behind it how we
came to it but it's very very logical it
doesn't speak to me I understand it I
can give like 10 lectures why would all
these matters important how we came to
this point like for the like if it's
trash on the floor and it's art I can
explain why but I am NOT it doesn't
speak to me it doesn't work with me
because art
you'd be the door from earth to the to
the sky should be like a door she's like
your window for you yeah if you want you
can open it if not you can just boom
interesting there is a door here okay so
well so ok so then art is like when
you're born there's like a little door
or we go and then like if you're
interested you can open that door look
through the window and what on the other
side art could be is art can be this
this expression of the biggest question
yes yeah yeah about why we're here
whatever this is that's cool of that
yeah this is this is my dream what are
what are should become we have that same
country I wish more media content was
about those big questions right now so
much of the media content is not
enlightening it's not reaching and it's
not very artistically cared for well and
if more media content can be like the
door the window into the biggest
questions like that's why we try and do
the show and we hope that more people
make art with that intention behind it
like you're talking about let's start
breaking down some of the art you've
been explaining it a little bit where
you take this high-def photo and then
you do the 3d and the Gildan techniques
but let's which which one do you want to
show I can
okay let's show that one yeah well you
want to okay okay cool it sounds good
let's do that alright so we'll switch to
this camera alright
okay go ahead and explain to us what's
happening here
[Music]
so this is always is the it calls fur
and bones serious
the Skull and Bones series fur and lows
oh the fur and bones series yeah that's
right that wasn't your video is called
fur and bones yeah
and yes they're breaking it down for us
okay I want you to be comfortable just
do this one at a time yeah you put down
on the keyboard yeah that's a good idea
yeah
so this calls fur and bones series and
in each image you can see either fur
either some skulls or bones and this is
kind of the idea about the duality of
life that we have our cool part and
shadow part and both of them we need to
accept and - for example when I only
started to draw I was drawing Angeles
for example and I was thinking this is
cool like this is like cool and
beautiful but where is the truth that
there's also the demon the dark yeah and
I also truly believe that art should
show the truth like oh yeah the
wholeness the the fullness so you show
then where's the duality here show us
the duo it's like the the whole series
is talked about this the whole series is
about different
I'd I would not even say that I put them
it's just somehow just peek through them
do you feel like the art comes through
you like it channels through you anta I
would say like what yeah I would say
that it's probably my process when what
I how it works for me that I started
something and then it's kind of like
warning born in it worn it owns me
and like Oh interesting oh that's what
is the okay okay so for example yes
oh I feel like I want this call here hmm
okay what what it what it talk what it's
telling me it's telling me something
about listen good interesting so then
would you would you say that in this
example that then we have you know
there's the fur here and then there's
this skull your many skulls yeah it's a
speak so loud because it's gold and
bright like that right and that's kind
of like it's that kind of it kind of
says a little bit about like the
fragility
the bunny but also kind of like this is
the body that you're experiencing life
through mm-hmm is that kind of like I'm
just I'm interpreting it myself in how I
feel yeah it's a good interpretation I'm
trying to remember the name of this part
but I don't remember it's something
about the mind
and this one's really like no one's very
it's kind of like on the other end of
sorts of the more serene tranquil on
maybe it could even be like has passed
but it kind of looks maybe a little bit
like telephone like levitate
levitational maybe mmhmm yeah I this
cause the soft power soft power yeah
that's right like if you it was like so
you can you can see that she has
something inside her that even like
light come through but it's soft so to
be powerful or strong it shouldn't be
like you you can be aggressive but it
can be also soft it would be very
powerful it's totally true we need more
men in leadership positions around the
world to tune into their sensitivities
and their emotions and vulnerabilities
in their spiritual selves and and women
if we men did that more and tuned in
deeper like that our world would have
less issues and be a better place yeah
100%
yeah it's the case yeah and it's very
interesting seeing more men around the
world do that and how some of the big
issues are slowly starting to get solved
in that sense so yeah okay
okay so yeah tell us more we have a lot
of we have a lot of art to show
and another layer if you see through all
like all the series is as the gold line
inside yeah and the gold line is it's in
every single piece of yours so that's
like your signature is the gold line one
of I mean one of many signatures yeah
yeah yeah totally yeah it's a very very
bright bright signature yeah yeah if you
put all this series in like one after
another you would also as you saw in the
video I was showing that this line goes
from this art and then continues to this
art and whenever it finishes like and if
you put it in the circle the first meets
the last yes you're thinking really far
in advance to when you're making them
that they have to connect like that and
be able to pull circle
ooh so then at some point you could uh
put like eight of them in like a circle
room and then yeah and the door you have
to like walk up from the bottom or like
climb a ladder yeah oh yeah yeah I have
like I have been like a little pile
where I am writing my ideas about the
exhibition's for example right now when
you go into exhibitions is just white
walls and art but just imagine if I mean
know a lot of artists do different not
I don't want to say all a lot of arts
too different but me but again just
imagine that you go inside and then boom
and it's dark and then boom you see some
sounds and then you somebody ask you to
take off your shoes and you feel that
you were in the water yes that's great
and then you see the light and then you
see this light goes and shows you for
example this Gold Line you know like it
could be very interactive and it could
be storytelling and not only art on the
wall but then you can use the a R or R
to see something even through the art
yeah this is what the future of
immersive experiences will be like and I
love how you're already thinking about
that that's so beautiful
ok yeah so so let's show quick I just
want to show so the gold you have
actually you've two lines here and then
you have the you have a couple circles
around and then here it's really unique
that she's also holding yeah / he's or
is that very clearly see that's a he
it's actually you know is still for
example angels they don't have a gender
boom there you go just like that I mean
but it is he okay yeah so this signature
is this called line that goes in from
first to the last and it's connected and
it says that we all connected ooh yeah
we're all interconnected yeah I love it
that's huge the gold line throughout and
how they connect between is important
for us to understand how we're all
interconnected and it helps from human
to human on the different pieces that we
are so interconnected like right now
even though I'm physically in a body and
you're physically in a body so many
people just think that's the end but
that's that's just it's a little tape
yeah because the way that we're
resonating together I mean the way that
we're using words and then how you're
interpreting the words and then how
what's coming from my heart and what's
coming from yours and what we're
co-creating in these moments and how
we're remembering these moments in time
together we're making massive imprints
on each other's existence and they're
super big interconnectedness between us
yeah that's yeah in like if you had to
if you felt something right now like
felt some sadness or if I felt some
ecstasy or whatever was like you would
feel my happiness or I would feel your
sadness there's a huge amount yeah yeah
yeah massively social and I'm glad that
that's speaks to the interconnectedness
yeah also for example I have one work
it's not here but I like it a lot it was
creepy but it has this angle the angle
of the face and then the angle of the
eyes whenever you would move in the room
it will just stare at you I think I
remember seeing it at your place yeah
yeah yeah does it see how do you do that
right these would say these are the
questions do you do you want to show the
other ones do you also want to show the
process yeah yeah of course
so the process because yeah how the heck
do you get those to look that way you
know yeah so this R sound
some pieces that I was trying before
printing all of them and yeah
so the first interesting detail is that
the paper that I'm printing in is has a
silver color hmm so when you look at it
especially on the blue ones see this
depth like here is a usual fabric and
it's pretty flat yeah
so here this is like even here but here
or there especially there you see and
it's kind of like greenish blue ish
silver ish yeah so it's like good a
little bit takes your like they're like
oh yeah this this silver paper is so ok
this depth and it takes you in yeah okay
okay so I'm using the silver paper and
then it's the matter of how to protect
the paper like you can use the the class
so this is I'm using the black sea glass
ready right here and there's a way of
Plexiglas yeah they're layer of back sea
glass and then the my question was how
to add this gold there and first I tried
to end it like right here on the on the
Plexiglas but actually it doesn't work
just because you can scratch it and it
goes away
yeah it looks cool because it's like
this 3d effect but you can't save it and
then I came to this print company and as
can we do can we try to do the cold
under and then they say that it's not
possible I said it's not possible which
you were like I'll show you know I'm
actually because oh my god because this
gold line is so much yeah it's your
signature yeah it's the 50% of the idea
or and I'm like I need this gold line
and so I asked them to make this piece
for me this small so they print it and
then I did this gold line and then they
put this plaque see under whoa yeah and
they said oh you know it's it's
surprisingly like we never done this
before but oh my god it worked
like likeéyou yeah so this was like
really gift behavior because Eric it
works so and what did we I don't think
you've mentioned this yet but how do you
do that how do you get this part I think
this is 3d and same thing with this part
yeah yeah this is 3d it's 3d well yeah
so what do you mean by how do you put
the 3d onto the photo so first what I'm
doing I'm creating the 3d model at
cinema 4d cinema 4d oh yeah it's like
software they suffer yeah and then and
some of them I made from scratch like
this mask cannibal lecture this was made
from scratch and these
skull was made from scratch actually
just downloaded indeed you downloaded
yes
the this yeah this cause I just used the
the - somebody made before me and then
the mask though you made from scratch in
cinema yeah so you create the forum yes
like mask and then you put the first
there and then you put all the lights
around in the new rendering thing okay
so the the mask came as just like a mask
that you could input and then you had to
like to add all the fur add the light
and then you could render it out and
then you would just put that on to like
two images yeah so this research image
is stacked on top of each other so it's
like the 2d photo plus the 3d rendering
on top of it plus the gold line yeah
okay okay yeah I mean and for example
this call it was really hard to find the
right angle
I was rendering probably like I don't
know maybe 10 times just because I meet
them both like this guy and this cow
look at the same direction and looks yes
yes so I got a lot of question actually
like if it's called truth like if what
if if their skull was there is that a
historic animal skull is that from like
a dinosaurs that from like a recent more
recent animal I think it's dinosaur oh
my gosh that's really cool yeah cuz
that's like 65 million years old yeah
yeah that's that's guys cool because
then now you're now you're mixing
together deep time like you're also
taking you know dinosaurs you know tens
of millions of years ago plus humans
today and putting those two
which already speaks like a deep time
yeah that's great and I think I can see
how many how long it took to try and get
the the face pointing in the same
direction like if I my head is tilted
this way you would need to keep
rendering those the dinosaurs face until
it go points in the same direction yeah
yeah I'm not even based like even I was
a bit low but they sort of it down oh
yeah yeah yeah so this is the process
and yeah and then after I this Goldline
success also there's a top like how we
can put it on the wall it also could be
different and cool because if you
remember there was lights not under but
I mean ant above but right below yeah
below yeah below the image and because
this this type of framing that I'm using
the actual without the frame right like
the frame without the frame you can just
put them on the wall without the frame
so it's also gives without with yeah
yeah so I don't know why but I just
don't like art in the frames just be I
dunno I love that principle yeah it's
like how can you put art into the frame
because then yeah how do you can you put
it in the frame and then also the frame
has to have something to do with the art
if the frame has nothing to do with the
art then it's so weird sometimes I guess
that could be art and so I think it
worked for something some other but for
me I just I just I just can't put the
art into to their friends just feels
like you know it's good like frame yeah
yeah
that's such a unique principle for it so
but those have frames yeah but those is
just because I wanted to because to
produce this it's actually very very
expensive yeah unfortunately so I wanted
to try to to see how people react on the
art fairs you know like art and vine
festival where people eat and buy art
yeah yeah so I wanted to put them there
and for that I need it to use as less
money as possible for selling them for
as less money as possible okay so I need
it and those frames you can like buy
them as they're already made this by
they're cheaper okay it's not a costume
it's this one so it was just for certain
circumstances that I needed to test how
it works for you normal people it's like
did like wine and yes
art in the video we saw the art in
galleries is that typically where you've
been able to you know tell us about the
timeline so like how long would it take
you to make one of these and then when
you do make one then how do you then
identify how do you find galleries to
put it in and and has it been are you
looking to sell or are you looking more
to inspire or both or both of those
things you know well this question is
always the hardest one for you know how
to bring this not useful just beautiful
things to sell or to or to get into the
galleries it's it's a question that I
was learning all this time and yeah it's
I know how to do it it takes a lot of
time and resources and a lot of efforts
and work and really hard work
so for now I'm I'm not represented in
the galleries I'm looking for for for
for this and I would be happy to do it I
also know that right now artists can
exist without the galleries and just
just with all the social media yeah you
can look you can exist without the gaol
yeah yeah yeah yeah which you are do
yeah people can easily just take on one
of the photos that you're posting on
your Instagram or website and just be
like I would love that in my house or
office or commercial property of any
sort and as an inspirational piece yeah
I love it is it door to questions yeah I
would love it as a door that's right
because people want people want
something profound for other people to
see how how you know you're like
universal they are so like people want
to put up your art in their home or
commercial property or wherever because
then when other people walk in they will
get inspired by that to think big but
also because then they'll be like ah
that person is smart because they think
big picture because they want people to
walk in and yeah yeah okay I see how
these things are all intertwine the
artist wanting big picture the person
that buys them wants the big picture for
other people that come in to have the
big picture it's yeah
yeah so the gallery the galleries is
it's cool but I also think that in San
Francisco is it's is still the city of
the IT mostly yep and art is like
pushing away slowly but as far as it's
possible oh my god
Silicon Valley so about software and
bits and and in Silicon Valley like
venture capital and it's I used to be in
the counterculture era like 50 ish years
ago it used to be a lot more art driven
and I think that's consciousness driven
and now it's like technology driven
which sometimes doesn't have
consciousness embedded in it like you
have to be making things consciously art
helps people awaken and make things more
consciously so like basically if art can
come into Silicon Valley fast enough it
will awaken the technologists that are
building technology unconsciously and
that's a massive component so like art
comes in and awakens the technologist
building the technology so they realize
well [ __ ] maybe what I'm doing is not my
most meaningful work and maybe I can
dedicate my brilliance to other more
meaningful projects around the world so
that's huge the be art community does
that your art community does exactly
that you guys do events once a week yeah
right TSA every Tuesday you're doing
events around different themes around
our different crafting styles yeah
that's huge and if we have more of these
be art community events happening then
people get the opportunity to get
inspired and actually make with their
hands and whatnot yeah
what other components should we talk
about regarding the art do you want to
show that process on your computer to
the multi oh yeah so I have I usually
delete all the versions that didn't work
but recently I was just working on this
new piece
and I saved all the variations on the
way and then I wondered maybe I
shouldn't delete them you know because
it all this process is actually super
interesting I'm so pumped to show
everyone this okay cool so do you see it
yes let's do it all so this way oh yeah
right yeah
so when I work on on the photography I'm
doing like different like maybe this no
this is no really this no or maybe that
and then some whenever and this portrait
didn't talk to me for a long time so
this is why I was making so many
variations
interesting so then what yeah what are
you what are you showing us there in
those variations and iterations like
could the process of searching for like
the right but there yeah for the right
feeling like oh this is yeah this is it
okay and in terms of like where you'd
put like the gold and where you'd put
like the which person you would choose
select which which photograph you'd use
of the person and which 3d addition
you'd add to it and which gilding
techniques you would use is that kind of
like you have like variations of which
not really it's not so conscious it's
more like more under the under the mind
yeah remember one time I think it was
with so this was the I just want to say
one time with an with the Delia who's
your partner the art just that she was
like helping me make that TEDx slides
but yeah and I was being so freaking
literal with like everything that I was
saying like super like logical and
brainy mmm-hmm and she was just like
very funny because she was making good
points and and ever since then and
practicing meditation and practicing
these different skills have dropped me
deeper into my heart and deeper into
feeling and deeper into art and
abstraction and things like that and
that's actually been extremely helpful
for me for seeing the world with both of
those
yeah yes so if you were just like Alan
that you're thinking way too much about
this like you're like feeling it more
yeah it's more like a conversation you
know because this is already something
that want to be alive
and it's not you're creating it's like
your your the flow between your you're
more like in terms you're more the past
yeah you're the pan
you're the best ideas coming through you
and your pen yeah yeah and you just need
to be the right color or they're the
right thickness of this pen right yes
and to write like to have the ink inside
yes so this more like feeling oh this is
it or oh it's not it oh I should go in
that place or in this way wow that was
really cool that you kind of gave me
another way of viewing how we're all
making those paint strokes as like pens
on society like our own expression is
our own stroke on the big canvas of our
world and then like within the pen or
like you know not only is it like the
color that you're picking the thickness
that you're picking then there's like is
it like an airbrush or like paint or
like you know mm-hmm whoa there's like
so many varieties of ways that people
can make an impact on on the world and
yeah
I'm such a synthesizer I'm always
synthesizing things into this big
narrative that hopefully will help
awaken people and also well that's on
the website yes so that's on the website
is links in the wild is that these
portraits also connect to the abstract a
portrait abstract portrait abstract so
this online continues and and for
example this is also in terms of geology
of the world so look to art work
together and at the same time if you put
on the wall three one two three they
work together like portrait abstract and
portrait or abstract portrait and
abstract again or just two absolutely no
portrait so it's just this I don't know
I'm just sometimes it's not that I was
specially thinking about this you know
it's just sometimes you created and and
they're like wow it works like that yeah
yeah so I'm just I'm just saying it yeah
this is works also like that
so all this layers when you create
something and then you see oh it's like
when you see the movie and the director
put there a lot of ideas and you're you
as the audience just try to guess all
this this this this so this feels for
making art falls for me that somebody
threw me created the movie and then yes
interesting way to look at it
is the amount of time that like the
director of a movie would put like all
the different layers into a scene and
that's kind of like what you're doing
with a piece of arts putting all the
layers into the scene and then you're
and then people can get inspired by
seeing back yeah so whenever you look at
the artworks first of all it's you for
example in the first time you can see oh
this is like Benari perception it's
beautiful and strange at the same time I
want to look at this and I want to walk
away just because it sometime is
stranger or or watching me you know as
that portrait or or it's it's very Asian
and old and it uses all techniques but
at the same it's very contemporary and
its uses wave forward techniques and the
next time you will see this fur and
bones everywhere in each single piece
and you would understand that bones is
about the body our structure that
believed and the fur is something
different that we can't even express or
imagine so for something light you're
like okay interesting and the next time
you will see something else yeah yeah
that's like when you look at something
especially with the age too because when
you're younger you don't know as much
about the world in reality and then when
you get older and you see it again
you're like oh my gosh I see it in a new
light yeah in a new way what we talked
about the future of art a bit and how
you have like this really deep Drive for
these immersive experiences to in the
future like I loved the way you were
describing leveraging all of the new
augmented reality style technologies but
also really cool immersive experiences
you have like someone's feet
like landing the water and like having
you can use scent you can use touch you
can use all the senses in one that's
like that's amazing
what else should we cover before the
last questions I think I don't know I
think you can't we can we can if you if
you want to ask something yeah you feel
pretty good about covering a decent
amount of the journey in the art feels
like we okay cool I like to make sure
that like especially because you have so
many unique creative things embedded in
your process that and in what it means
and how it inspires I just wanted to
make sure that we got to the most
important stuff I think so yeah all
right let's ask you do you think we're
in a simulation okay what is in this
simulation like in matrix right kind of
um we also maybe could say like you know
what is reality what is reality real is
it being simulated okay what would be
even the difference okay yeah yes so
what I think that
I actually I I would say that I think
I'm not sure that I truly feel it but I
think that always this dream of yeah
just some godless and it will just it is
a second but at the same time it's a
millions and billions of years so it's
everything you know it's like a point it
can be like a little or a huge yeah yeah
well I mean is something that I'm just
probably I've heard it somewhere and
it's just resonated with me I wouldn't
say that I truly found it in any way but
this is if you ask me what I truly think
this is what I think like I think there
is all
a dream of one creature that we're apart
we are all part of it and then they woke
up and boom
yeah so it could be that then the
timeline of evolution and all that is is
then compressed and condensed down into
the simple dream of of God or this
artistic expression of it like it's kind
of like there could potentially be so
many of these evolving around happening
and the beauty of it is if you try and
compress this universe down into that
little tiny bit and you like run that
one down then you compress another one
and run that one you just like observe
them all try and understand them look at
how they all evolved like what is the
art behind it what is it a science
behind it yeah it's like for example you
take the paper and then you put water
there and then you brush in watercolor
and you just put push this brush stroke
and then the color just spread out in
the color so we want me this brush
stroke of the watercolor on the yes
especially because then there's like the
observer that says well interesting and
then we are all in that also going whoa
interesting so all a billion of us and
all of the sentient solve the other
animals plants etc are all like you know
aw interesting and meanwhile on this
side too that did the creation is also
interesting at the same time like
Wow and then what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world I
know I think maybe life itself like like
like how everything is created like I
have this body with the blood inside and
it works and I can breathe so somehow it
create and this is the beauty or how
they solve the circulation of water in
the air and ocean and everywhere so yeah
I think this is the beauty is the
beautiful structure of everything like
it it exists
we're in our mind never can understand
like how yeah and this is I think this
is the muting like oh my god this exists
yes oh my gosh yes yes yes the fact that
there is something instead of nothing
and that there's something that exists
is has the bodies that have the part in
the organs inside that keep us alive in
the the beauty of the all the cyclical
processes on the planet like the water
cycles and the cycles of life and life
is so magnificently beautiful and
sometimes we get stuck in the yeah just
like fall in love with other humans
yeah and just be like you are divine
being that is making such coolness and
then if the other person can also
reciprocated feel similarly I mean
they'll change our whole civilization if
people start feeling that way on a
moment-to-moment basis do you think it's
possible yes Volken start you like all
of them oh my god is such a good
question because even I like I would say
that in general I feel that my but still
I am so I have a lot of time when I fall
into some fears or like I'm not enough
or I need to do this or I need to to the
killer I need to get to the galleries oh
my god they're rejecting me or maybe
it's more you know and it you just start
to so instead of your mind see all this
beautiful picture is just stuck in this
very strange place and just run this
circle well and that that's part of the
challenge is to be able to mass
they're ones own mind and
stream-of-consciousness because then you
get let you get less trapped in those
spirals and that that's part of the
experience is learning how to master
that and making it something that you
care about doing and learning a lot
because then you don't end up being
dragged around by emotion or other
people's desires and and whatnot but you
get full control of yourself and then
you get to do things like artistically
express yourself like that your thing
that you said about galleries like
there's different ways to look at it
there's the way of oh my god I'm not
getting into enough galleries oh my god
there's the other way which is like I
should enquire with more galleries that
would be a good idea and then there's
the other way which is like it's totally
cool I'm just gonna lay back and wait
until people come to me right so there's
all different ways of looking at the
same scenario but to be in those loops
of negative or text to like we have to
figure out how to meditate we have to
figure out it take control of our
thoughts so that we don't get stuck in
those loops as much and we have to
figure out how to all feel more alive on
a moment-to-moment basis and can
interconnected with each other just like
your gorgeous Gold Line show us yeah
yeah I've had such a blast thank you
thank you for listening because honestly
I not often talk like that just because
I understand that the person on the
other side wouldn't resonate so some or
wouldn't understand so sometimes I'm not
talking about everything that I truly
think or like put or found out about my
art I would say instead of this I would
say oh this is this and that like in a
very matter like manner like like like
trying of water in the ocean like okay
I'm not going that I just described that
this is just just look at this beauty
just feel your sense when you feel the
beauty and the fear and people oh yeah I
feel the beauty and the fear at the same
time and this is our conversation might
stop in in this point and not go further
just because I understand it I it will
not work but it would be just too too
much so here I truly felt that I can
tell my story this is like very
malleable thank you thank you for saying
that too because that's one of the main
principles of the show is that the
guests that come on the show for them to
feel like they're coming at their best
from their heart and that they're
teaching and sharing and inspiring and
that's for you to have felt like you
could go and be your best is so
important and and actually you know as
you were saying that to I I also I also
realize that
there's just something about that
feeling that we need more shared around
the world like if we can take what we
feel is like this big gold nugget like
if you have some gold nugget you have a
piece of wisdom and you want to go and
share it with other people sometimes you
got to be very careful with who you
share it with because if you have
something really inspirational you share
it with someone that doesn't get it they
might stop you from doing that
inspirational thing so like when you
find people that really ask you lots of
questions about your work and they're
really excited and interested about it
hold them more closely and like ask them
more questions and that's like the same
thing with with whatever people are
building around the world is that just
make sure that you're identifying people
that care about what you're doing and
asking them more questions about it
because these are like the people that
are closer on the bell curve of like
understanding you and will who you are
and what you care about and so don't let
necessarily people discourage you but at
but some other times you can be saying
something that's kind of like really
like instead of progressive on the bell
curve it can be like regressive on the
bell curve and if it's like saying
something about we should still enslave
people right it's like no like no
horrible idea bad idea like you know
I've had so much fun learning about you
and your art thank you saying you for
coming on the show thank you so much for
coming on yeah thank you for inviting
and asking super welcome and I'm really
grateful that we had the beautiful
pieces to share with you guys thank you
so much for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online on social media about
contemporary sacred art about the things
that Ksenia was teaching us about on the
show about the big questions and about
how making art can help inspire people
to think
about the big questions and feel into
those big questions and make art like
that yourselves check out the links in
the bio below to her website and her
Instagram page go and support her and
also support the artists and
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders
organizations around the world that you
believe in supports simulation help us
grow as well our patreon or
cryptocurrency our PayPal link is down
there and also you can design cool merch
and get paid all those links are down
there and also build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon